jordan peele's nope left some audiences
saying hell yeah others however were
ready to get out of theaters
the opening scene of nope is a
viscerally horrifying experience that
puts viewers on edge while setting up
the themes of the film all at the same
time it's almost entirely quiet and
comprised of a single simple shot a
chimp and a birthday hat covered in
blood on the set of a television show
it's clear that the chimp has run amuck
and savagely mauled the girl who may or
may not be dead chimp attacks on their
own are terrifying but coming at the
very start of a film supposedly about
aliens it's as upsetting as can be one
reddit user wrote it's truly the
scariest scene in my opinion in this
movie it makes you want to look away but
the feeling of needing to know what
happens next is curiosity taking over
following the opening scene we meet otis
haywood senior and his son oj
unfortunately the haywood patriarch is
badly wounded by falling debris he
abruptly stops moving and sags atop the
horse he is riding after he's rushed to
the hospital we find out that a nickel
fell from the sky through otis senior's
head and fatally embedded itself in his
brain while that would be upsetting
enough some fans have picked up on a
more insidious part of the scene as one
reddit user points out the overall theme
of nope is trying to profit off things
you really probably shouldn't profit
from what kills keith david's character
is money falling from the sky
for the sheer number of comments it's
obvious that one of the most upsetting
sequences in nope is when the saucer
sucks up the crowd at jup's show the
scene itself is gruesome but the
implications of what comes next are even
worse the saucer is no alien aircraft
but rather an animal itself which means
that the crowd is actually being
digested instead of just abducted an
exchange between two reddit users sums
up the scene's implications well so what
they're being slowly digested while
suspended in air for hours i guess until
it blenders them for something
sporadically throughout nope chillingly
vague screams echo throughout the canyon
usually when the saucer is in sight the
movie spends a long time sprinkling the
screams throughout before it ever even
hints at an explanation on top of that
the screams seem to come from multiple
beings at once sounding like any number
and combination of people and animals
even before the spine-chilling sounds
are explained they managed to upset fans
to their core one reddit user was one of
the first to cite the pervasive screams
as one of the most upsetting parts of
nope saying that their screams from the
clouds was horrible too and then
suddenly cut off chills the screams make
the digestion scene even worse implying
that the saucer carries its victims in
its stomach for days slowly and
painfully digesting them one fan writes
i'd never seen that in a monster movie
before the monster's victim still alive
inside it and screaming giving you a
sense of the bean's location but in a
way that is more terrifying than useful
and then it swallows them
we are making something new and special
and something that is a testament to why
i love movies
and of course the digestion scene leads
directly to one of the most horrifying
moments in the entire film the
bloodrayne scene the scene which is
already being compared to the infamous
elevator blood scene from the shining
sees em and angel trapped in the ranch
house overnight the saucer menacingly
hovering directly over them like we had
seen before small metal objects begin
falling from the sky clinking against
the house's walls and windows then the
rain switches to a torrent of dark red
blood which repaints the formerly white
building red for the rest of the movie
yeah they repainted your house as we
gradually come to realize the blood in
all the metal objects that had ever
fallen from the sky were actually the
saucer creature expelling its waste one
user wrote that we see the jean jacket
vomit the objects it cannot digest then
you wonder what's next will it destroy
the house attempting to kill em and
angel nope blood starts to slowly pour
in a terrifying shininesque sequence
we already covered the opening scene
which jumpstarts fan terror with images
of a bloody gorty in his victim but nope
has much more gorty violence to parade
out later in the movie after some
balloons unexpectedly pop on set the
chimp burst into a murderous rage
brutally mauling his co-stars the one
exception is a young juke who gordy
leaves unharmed the sequence did not sit
well with fans at all one reddit user
wrote that the entire scene was so
nerve-wracking especially when he sees
young juke under the table and just
stares into the camera my anxiety was so
high while another fan wrote the gordy
scene was masterfully done and stuck
with me as truly unsettling
the vast majority of nope moments that
upset fans were pretty purposefully
meant to invite discussion they either
delivered on the film's promise of
horror or delivered on its social
commentary in both cases nailing that
sweet spot so typical appeals work but a
few of the upsetting moments seem to be
drawing such ire from viewers because
the suspension of disbelief is being
broken case in point the praying mantis
which has already begun to generate its
own discussion threads for its absurdity
and convenience to the plot the insect
in question appears at the exact moment
the haywoods try to film the saucer it
covers a digital camera that angel
prepared beforehand throughout the
entire alien encounter and flies away of
its own record the moment the saucer
leaves preventing any useful recording
as one reddit user commented the use of
the mantas felt weak and flimsy their
setup would have worked fine if not for
the praying mantis though and they
abandoned that setup after one try
they're right given that oj specifically
comments on how rare the bugs are in
that area making the moments even more
frustrating and though other users
considered the insect's presence just
another bad miracle the sheer
coincidence of the insect being such an
obstacle to the haywood's success
doesn't make it any less upsetting that
said it's worth noting that peel likely
meant for this moment to be upsetting to
fans on purpose the scene becomes even
more suspenseful not just because of the
danger that the saucer poses to oj but
because it's up to emerald to try to
remove the insect in time to capture the
saucer on video if fans were upset that
the haywoods didn't succeed when the
movie wasn't even half over that just
shows that they were invested in
characters
to some fans the choices and actions of
antlers holst may be the most annoying
parts of nope the character is superbly
played by michael wincott is presented
throughout the film as a true master of
his craft he's an old school guerrilla
filmmaker and an incredibly talented
cinematographer he chooses his projects
carefully and it's clear that he values
integrity and intelligence over all else
in his career that's why it's so
aggravating when holst agrees to help
the haywards film the saucer and
seemingly blows it the supposedly expert
filmmaker decides to take both himself
and his never-before-seen world-changing
footage of the saucer creature and
voluntarily feed himself and it to the
saucer after all this time trying to
capture the perfect shot of the creature
he succeeds but only by throwing his own
life away the act has prompted a number
of dedicated discussion threads such as
what was up with antler holst and the
climax my theory about holston is
sacrifice and the most direct of all
what antlers holst did was very stupid
can you guys explain why he would have
done that
with all of the intersecting messages
and nope centered around the dangers of
dehumanization disrespecting living
beings trying to control predators and
putting spectacle ahead of empathy some
inattentive viewers think it was not
choice for the movie to end with the
creature murdered by m to these fans the
scenes involving gordy and his effect on
juke's later life were meant as examples
of what not to do those who try to
dominate dangerous animals and harm them
for selfish gain risk violent
retribution and moral compromise the
same is seemingly true for the scenes
involving oj and his horse lucky and how
the pair were treated on a commercial
set the theme supposedly carries into
the third act as the cast prepares to
get the perfect shot of the creature
however one fan believes that the third
act actually leads to oj taming the
creature that was jean jacket showing
respect to oj oj challenged it in one
and after that revealed its true self to
him seeing him as an equal and let him
live another fan added that respect is
given shown and taken in most animal
species it's not a human specific
characteristic these fans seem to
believe that the scene featured a
genuine bond between oj and jean jacket
which would make the creature's death a
confusing choice of course considering
that jean jacket is directly responsible
for the death of o.j and hems father on
top of being a bloodthirsty killer of
both people and horses it may be safe to
say that gene jacket's comfort wasn't
exactly the top priority for the
haywoods
by its end nope reveals itself to be
anything but the alien movie most
viewers expected what is initially
believed to be a spaceship containing
alien visitors from another planet turns
out to be an organism itself a massive
flying predator that sucks people and
animals into its saucer-like body to eat
them not probe them sorry angel
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
and while the film's characters still
seem to believe the creature is alien in
origin there is not necessarily anything
in the film to suggest that the creature
is anything but a previously
undiscovered species of animal this
twist turning an alien invasion movie
into a creature feature is playful and
fresh that doesn't stop fans of alien
invasion movies from being disappointed
he'll certainly build the movie as an
alien movie even citing the recent
release of previously unseen government
footage of ufos is an inspiration
however the lack of explicit
confirmation within the world of the
film seems to have angered some viewers
[Music]